the wild
the weaver
[Music]
and the worm
three primal forces from which the world
gaia springs
the wild is creation
formless and abundant
the weaver
shapes making order out of chaos
the worm
whose purpose was to destroy the old to
make room for the new one went
mad
now a force of corruption feeding on
greed malice and hate
it ravages gaia
through its unwitting accomplices
mankind
the balance between those three forces
is long gone now
insidiously
the worm gains more and more ground
every day
vitalized by the damage humans have
brought to the earth
we
the werewolves remain
born of man beast and spirit
we
are the vindication of gaia
and
the wild
all right
they should be ready now
the best way to get indrin out of the
region is to attack their bottom line
we have a plan to convince them there's
no profit to be had here
but miller
if you please
i've recently gained access to the
system that controls all the on-site oil
pumps
that's our target we tamper with the
and send dummy data to the system to
make them think their oil field is run
dry will that really be enough
according to the internal files i got my
hands on they treat unprofitable sites
like gangrenous limbs they'll give this
one the chop right away
so how do we go about this rotco
who does what ludmilla knows the
location so she will take point she'll
infiltrate the site and connect eva to
their network giving her access to their
system
once i'm hooked up i'll only need a few
minutes
but if something goes wrong my wife ends
up on her own in enemy territory
i don't like it i'm going to be fine
call
we've been preparing this for weeks
we've calculated the risks and if
there's any sign of trouble you and i go
in and retrieve her
but i'd rather we stay covert
miller will have the easiest time on her
own
i'm heading out
i want to be done before daybreak
take care of adana while i'm away
i think she's going a little crazy all
cooped up in
here don't worry i'll talk to her you
just focus on your mission
call
i've got this
i love you
see you soon
endrin
one of the most destructive companies
north america has to offer known for
their violence and endless greed
if we left them to their own devices
they'd ravage this place so there was
nothing left but dust
i don't like thinking that ludmilla's on
her own rodko
i understand
she's my sister remember
what about rafiq he never leaves his
lupus shape no one would have noticed
him
i gave it a lot of thought
her chances of success are better if
she's alone it's as simple as that
if things don't go as planned you can
tear through as much endurance scum as
you like to get her out
but for now
we stay put
go
rest while we wait
we've been stuck in this cave for weeks
studying engines movements
at least now we finally got a plan
i hope we're done here soon
not looking forward to packing all this
up tomorrow morning
got everything squared away
not a lot too square away all i'm doing
is pressing a button once lumila gets me
hooked up
still got a ways to go before i can do
much more than that if i tried to breach
their network they'd be on us in a
second
says the woman who got her hands on
their files
we'd never have been able to take the
fight to engine like this without you
that's sweet coho but i just wish i
could do more
but how are you doing
talk to your daughter yet
no not yet
i'm just heading her way
david did an impressive job installing
all this
not that she'd ever admitted she still
has so much self-doubt
hey
how you doing
i'm bored out of my mind there's nothing
to do here and it's wet and miserable
don't worry our work here is nearly
finished you'll be back at the cairn
with your friends before you know it
i know but why'd you have to drag me out
here in the first place
it's not like you've got me doing
anything out here
your mom wanted you to come along
so you could see what our field missions
entail
they entail a bunch of [__] all we
ever do is watch and take notes we're
not accomplishing anything
language young lady
and preparation is key
know how your enemy will respond before
you move
faux stripped of surprise is fangless
why didn't you go with mom anyway
she's all alone out there if something
happens to her
i wish i could have
but rodko wants us to keep a low profile
and there's no one better at that than
your mom
rodko's a dumbass
hey that's your uncle you're talking
about
and the leader of our pack
you know it's his job to make those
decisions
and like i said all that observation we
were doing was minimizing the danger
your mother will be just fine eddie
don't worry
[__]
wake up i'm gonna need you
a helicopter just touched down on the
site's landing pad
apparently it's some endron exact their
presence is shaking things up
shaking things up how
guard patrols have been changed and some
areas have been locked down including
the one luke mill is in they still
haven't discovered her though
so what's the plan now
the mission sunk we go in there get her
out and wait for things to quiet down
but to get her off site the locked off
areas need to be manually unlocked and
lukemill is stuck on the wrong side
[__]
fortunately she has already secured a
terminal she'll guide you to her
location over the radio
go now bring her back
there's no time to waste my sister needs
you
ludmilla i'm on my way
remember
stay out of sight
i'll open any door i have access to
through their network i've opened all
the external ducts
i'm locked in the turbine room in the
center of the site
you'll have to get here without being
seen
the area you're passing through should
be deserted right now though
door's locked
ava
there's got to be a terminal close by
find it oh and uh deactivate any cameras
you see while you're at it
guards
i'm looking at the southern part of the
outer fence
and a [__] ton of guards
there's no way i'll be able to make a
move without being seen
southern part of the outer fence
got it
there
he won't live long enough to raise the
alarm
they sold their souls to end ron
they don't get any mercy hell of a time
for a malfunction
i'll go check it out
any idea what could have caused it
i just want it fixed and fast some big
shot just arrived on site folks upstairs
want everything to be perfect
huh
oh
i'm in the refinery
perfect
i'm not far now
nearly in the passageway leading into it
something's following me
what is it
i think it's a black spiral dancer
keith
but miller just hold on
[__]
ronco
i heard no more sneaking around we fight
now go i'll beat you with rafiq i'm done
[__] around
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
we need more
[Music]
in the next room
um
just watch out
uh
we can't stop him
it's
keep going
think i should needed able to
back there
gorilla
no
please no
[Music]
thank you
no
food miller
it's me cajole
listen to me
oh damn it
no
you need to fight the rage
oh let's refreeze stop it
what have i done rafiq there's no time
to mourn
we need to go
uh
fought
just reported back to base
not that there's anything to report no
kidding
though i guess we've got a special guest
coming tonight
yeah an engine rep no less
she should be here soon you know they're
hiring right think you'd ever make the
move to andren
hey
all clear dusk we're good to go
five years ago i abandoned the woods of
tucker's mill
i abandoned my cairn
engine killed my wife
i gave in to rage
the worm touched my soul
i had to leave my
daughter it was the hardest decision i
ever made
and in other news andren is joining the
fight against global warming the energy
company today announced that their new
biofuel will be hitting the market soon
this revolutionary new formula will be
unveiled alongside the opening of their
new headquarters
this exile was my only choice
i'd become a danger to my pack
i often wonder what's become of them
with rotco
ava
of 80.
[Music]
this is the closest i've been to
tucker's mail in five years
alcohol
we're here
you're off
how much time do we have before they
notice the guards on the outside have
gone quiet
they report in by radio every hour
that's our deadline for getting our
hands on the explosives and getting out
of here
let's go through the plan again
just to make sure everything's clear
you've got to swap the delivery label on
the creative explosives intended for
andrew you do that and they'll load us
up with smiles on their faces all you've
got to do is open the gate to their
delivery bay for me i'll create a
diversion while you're exchanging the
labels
got it we'll have to play it tight
though
one hiccup and the plan falls through
we'll have you sneak around back by
their storage facility security should
be pretty thin there especially if you
go through the ventilation docks
what do your clients intend to do with
them anyway
weather stormers
they're planning on blowing up a big
magadon pharmaceutical plant good
[__] ribbons
i know megadon's methods
they're the scum of the earth
guess what these explosives were
originally headed to endrin
another mega corp of [__] stealing
from them is just icing on the cake
all right
i'm off hey before you go are you sure
you're up for this man you seem kind of
stressed out back in the truck
just been a long time since i've been
out this way
brings back memories
forget it we've got a job to do
right if you need me i'm just a chirp
away good luck brother
i'm inside
reached out to me you know
they're hiring in the pace pretty good
i'm sure it is
they're going toe-to-toe with a group of
activists right now lambda mankind
security breach
hello there
uh
you hear the new android announcement
about their new bio fuel they say
they're going green
the only thing green about that fuel is
the label
it's the same [__] with new branding a
marketing stunt
now we're talking
they're not running the most attractive
operation here
i mean they're pumping out weapons for
entrance not selling time shares looks
probably not their priority
i made it to the delivery bay
good see that command post next to the
gate you should be able to open things
up for me from there
okay
hold up
dusk
you're up
once i've got their attention you go
find what we came for and slap on this
fancy new delivery label got it
hey you in the truck what are you doing
here i'm just here for a pickup man
pickup what are you talking about
there's no pick up on the schedule well
check it again i i gotta be on there you
really think i'd drive all the way out
to the ass end of nowhere if i didn't
have a pickup all right all right but
i'm gonna have to search that truck then
we'll see about that pickup
knock yourself out bud
one right there
dusk
you're up
once i've got their attention you go
find what we came for and slap on this
fancy new delivery label got it
hey you in the truck what are you doing
here
i'm just here for a pickup man pickup
what are you talking about there's no
pickup on the schedule well check it
again i i got to be on there you really
think i'd drive all the way out to the
asset of nowhere but they didn't have a
pickup all right all right i'm gonna
have to search that truck then we'll see
about that pickup
knock yourself out
[Music]
according to the intel we received the
crates of explosives should be stored
around here
all right dusk the delivery label's been
switched
it's time for us to get the hell out of
dodge
wait
i smell something
give me a minute to check it out
i knew i smelled it
silver
whoever ordered this intends to kill
garu
dusk they're shipping out silver bullets
you know what that means
change plans
change of plans
i need to find out who's buying these
bullets and why
buy me some more time
so who's the lady the boss is meeting
with upstairs
she's from andrew here for the special
order the silver bullets who even uses
that [__]
is she picking up some golden guns while
she's at it you know what they say the
client is king especially when the
client's name is endring
shipments loaded how are things on your
end
shouldn't be much longer
you were supposed to have to look at an
ammunition one week ago
one week
endrin doesn't like waiting or paying
clearly you're not getting anything
until end is paid up you can tell that
to your president watkins in person
i don't think you understand what's at
stake here
oh i understand that you've just been
attacked and you're looking to hit back
i also understand that you need our
ammunition to do that and we've got that
ammunition right downstairs
ready and waiting to go
as soon as you've paid us
sorry major the business is business
well [__] you two then we'll attack
parker's mill without your help and rest
assured mr watkins will hear about this
tucker's mill
hey
you and i need to talk
who are you how'd you get in
i'm asking the questions who are you
talking to the woman
and what's this attack on turker's mill
i'm calling security going
security
back up right now
backup squad
here
parker's
oh
my old karen
donna
i have to go back
[__] back here already
sorry but i didn't have a choice
keep the engine running we're out of
here as soon as i get back
the alarm went off in the boss's office
but i'm not getting any response from
that sector
take your positions people
maximum alert until the situation's
clear
uh
hmm
i'll flush him out
huh
what hostile you've got an intruder
let's do this thing
uh
[Music]
stuff
delivery baby
[__] what's going on
[Music]
huh
hostile
dispatch
we need
we need a backup spot
so
three encouragements
[Music]
what intruders
where we headed parker's mill
we're too late engine is already here
what do we do
stop the truck
what's even down there
my home dusk stay out of this
wait call
ronco
radco they've cleared our northern line
they have an exo we'll take care of the
wounded later
we have to stop them
let's go
move
[Music]
over there
[Applause]
right
rocco
you'll regret that
clever boy
ultra fall back
[__] silver
tell me where's the donna don't worry
carl
your daughter didn't fight this battle
how are your wounds
riddled with silver
they'll take days to heal
but things would have been far worse if
you hadn't stepped in
i just did what i had to do
nothing more
i honestly never thought i'd see your
face again
why'd you come back all
i heard that the cairn was gonna be
attacked
i was afraid for you
for a donna
and how did you hear that
i overheard endrin talking about it on
my last job
i may have left talker's mill but i
never turned my back on it
i couldn't just abandon you
you found it easy enough five years ago
your cairn and your daughter have always
needed you i tried to tell you that
where is she rotgo
with ava
working undercover at the biggest
hindrance site in the pacific northwest
best option available to us after the
failure of our last mission
rodko you let it donna infiltrate andrew
my [__] daughter
after what happened with her mother
your daughter is the best undercover
agent i have
we will not win our fight for gaia
without first bringing indran down and
with your daughter on the inside
we're closer than ever
she may not fight like we do
but she's every bit as strong
you should respect that
the work she's doing inside indrin is
absolutely vital
more so after what their private [__]
army just did to us i'm afraid her work
won't be able to stop indrin from
retaliating against us
not after our last mission
your last mission
what do you mean
you remember the old abandoned mine not
far from here
hendren bought it and turned it into a
training center for their new recruits
and launched an attack to wipe them out
but tank girl stopped us
the woman you saw in the exo during the
attack she drove us back
tank girl you call her
i encountered her during my last mission
she was trying to buy silver bullets
from her arms deal
that's where i learned she was planning
an attack on the cairn
major greener
that's the name her men give her
but to us
she's tank girl
and she leads entrance troops with about
as much grace their attack on the cairn
was their first wave of revenge for our
attack on the training center we managed
to repel them this time
but it's only a temporary victory
they might return at any moment
and end
just keeps recruiting soldiers then
we've got to go back to the mine and
destroy their training center
it's the only way to buy the care in any
sort of safety
no matter how brief
go back
no
not until i'm well again
then we can strike
tell me about ava how's she doing
when you went into exile
she succeeded you as my lieutenant she
was ready and willing but it was hardly
a smooth transition
i was forced to make
some concessions
i can imagine
there are a lot of humans in the camera
a lot more than when i was here
he was lamb to mankind
i'd heard about her group of activists
they're actually getting a lot of
attention at the moment
not sure if that's the best thing for
the pack
that's what i thought too
at first
what do you mean
for the longest time
i never trusted humans
but then i saw how they fought
how they stood strong for what they
believed in
i saw their potential
even i had to admit that ava was right
the humans have been
stalwart allies in our fight for gaia
now you've seen firsthand what indran is
doing to us
our ranks grow thinner every year
ava's humans
aren't afraid to put their lives on the
line for the planet
what more could i ask for
until i'm healed
there's no way we can make a move on the
training center
i'll take care of that goddamn training
center myself
you know i can handle it on my own
no
you're no longer a part of this pack
it's my responsibility
and how long will it take for you to get
there days
weeks
if they return the cairn will fall
i'll think about it
go pay your respects to your fen and
come back to me
then we'll talk about the mine
but the cannon is in a bad way
agnes didn't even know how to fight
he was a spirit healer a caretaker of
children
kendra doesn't show anyone mercy
it has been many a year
since i last felt your presence
warrior of gaia
it's been nearly as long since anyone
called me that
your care needs you
and the wild has need of your protection
the eater of souls is fighting with all
his might to take control of it
and
he is winning
the corruption takes many forms
but the effects
are always the same but
you
must help us fight back
tucker's mill looks nothing like it did
when i left
yet you still protected the forest with
everything you had
your strength
your aura
what happened to them
as gaia weakens
so too
do i
the
anglings the jacklings
the gafflings
they all suffer in kind
the eater of souls tries to corrupt them
but they're minor spirits
they are every bit as important as you
or i
but in my
weakness
i must look on
powerless to act
as they disappear
which is why
we need your help
[Music]
you must help me to combat the worm
to protect the wild
i came back to find my daughter
have you seen her
i've got
a dear friend
and always respectful of nature
you fear for her safety then
she too
is fighting for gaia
in her own way
but do not worry
you both walk the same path
you will find each other in time
to fight your battles
you will need power
power i can provide by helping you
develop your warrior gifts
thank you efen
you may find lost spirits during your
travels
return them to me
and i will be able to strengthen your
natural abilities
one last request before you depart
many of your kin fell in combat
i would ask you to bury them
you will find their bodies both inside
and around the camera
your pen number of vision will show you
the way
soothe their souls and send them to me
so that they may travel to the wild
without being captured by the worm
i will if i can
but my priority is entrance training
center
weaken the forces of the worm there
but
never forget your brothers and sisters
gaia needs you
leandra
i hope broadcast changed his mind
i went to see fenn
he's gotten so weak
please rocco let me help you
let me deal with this training center
why is it that you care now call
we were so easy to ignore when we went
right in front of you
what
you want to be part of the pack again
i want to help the pack
i want to protect adana but you don't
intend to rejoin us
i've already given into rage and killed
one of our kin rodko
i can't take the risk of doing it again
you already know i disagree
nonetheless
we are united by those we mourn
so i'll accept your help
so what can you tell me about this
so-called training center
ava managed to get a hold of the mind
blueprints to help us prepare for our
previous attack the site's weak point is
its power supply
they apparently haven't had the time to
give it a proper upgrade
the whole thing is powered by one big
propane tank just like it was when it
was a mine
i see
so if i blow up the tank the whole minor
cave in taking the training center with
it i am indeed
your friend gave me the explosives that
you stole as soon as he arrived
dusk is here yeah
he arrived just after the attack
don't worry
i asked the humans to look after him
we've still got a problem though
you don't know the layout of the site
and i'm too injured to go with you
i don't like touching the stuff
but i suppose i'll use ava's radio
equipment to guide you that should do
the trick
perfect so we'll stay in radio contact
take the explosives and go
good luck aha